bene immaginiamo che Giulia torni a casa
la sera dal lavoro stanca come su
abitudine si prepara in fretta qualcosa
da mangiare prende la bottiglia di vino
il bicchiere una scatola di biscotti e
si accomoda sul divano per vedere la sua
serie tv preferita e mentre guarda la
serie TV mangia parecchi biscotti quasi
finisce la scatola la mattina dopo si
sveglia piuttosto appesantita e anche la
bilancia non dà buone notizie e mentre
va al lavoro Giulia dice Insomma devo
veramente cambiare qualcosa così non
posso continuare la sera torna a casa
piena di buona volontà ma ripete il suo
solito rituale dice Ma sì vabbè dai Per
stasera va così domani Domani comincio
ma
è così difficile così complicato
iniziare un cambiamento Da dove Da dove
si comincia
alimentarsi bene mangiare bene fare più
attività fisica
se vogliamo investire bene anche i
nostri soldi o
risparmiare sviluppare il nostro
potenziale lavorativo
spesso sappiamo che cosa dovremmo fare o
cosa vorremmo fare anche ma cambiare la
nostra abitudine È piuttosto difficile
allora è possibile attraverso la
comunicazione stimolare accompagnare il
cambiamento delle persone verso il
benessere ed è possibile farlo in una
maniera trasparente ed efficace e anche
una maniera che non faccio sentire la
persona manipolata magari infastidita
Perché Qual è il rischio Il rischio è
quello di avere un effetto boomerang
cioè peggiorare ulteriormente la
situazione ma è possibile farlo non solo
con Giulia con una persona ma con 10 100
1000 10.000 persone
da un po' di tempo nel nostro gruppo di
ricerca ci stiamo interrogando su questi
su questi temi e abbiamo ci siamo anche
chiesti oltre a fare varie ricerche se
le tecnologie le nuove tecnologie
avrebbero potuto un po' aiutarci in
questo in questa attività ed è così che
pian piano è nata La strana coppia
psicologia sociale e intelligenza
artificiale
La psicologia sociale aiuta a capire
quali sono le caratteristiche che
possono spingere una persona a cambiare
a capire
come adattare la comunicazione quando
parli con diverse persone capire In che
stadio di cambiamento la persona si
trova ma l'intelligenza artificiale può
dare un Boost può diciamo potenziare
quello che la psicologia sociale può
fare perché Innanzitutto può rendere
automatici alcuni di questi processi che
la psicologia sociale studia può
rivolgersi a tante tante persone
contemporaneamente ma allo stesso tempo
adattarsi personalizzare il tipo di
messaggio che mai che manda quindi
insieme psicologia sociale intelligenza
artificiale possono creare dei processi
automatici che sono integrabili nei vari
canali di comunicazione digitale Come
accade questo attraverso alcuni step
vediamo un po' i principali il primo
step lo possiamo chiamare quello del
profi cioè capire quali sono le
caratteristiche psicologiche quelli che
possiamo chiamare i driver che davvero
possono aiutare le persone a cambiare e
così Giulia per esempio
può darsi che improvvisamente sentendo
il discorso di una influencer che lei
stima molto e che parla in questa
direzione decida di cambiare in questo
caso che fattore ha giocato in lei un
fattore sociale un fattore legato alle
relazioni oppure Cosa succede Giulia non
riesce più a mettersi un vestito che le
piaceva tantissimo vuole sentirsi più
bella in questo caso ha giocato un
fattore di motivazione o ancora Giulia
in una di quelle famose serate mangia
davvero troppi biscotti la notte sta
male vive un'emozione davvero negativa e
quindi in questo caso un'emozione
potrebbe portarla improvvisamente a
decidere davvero di cambiare
La questione è che Giulia è fatta così e
che i fattori che entrano in gioco sono
tanti per alcuni sono certi per altri
sono altri quindi la cosa è complessa
non solo i fattori che contano possono
cambiare la stessa Giulia potrebbe dare
importanza a cose diverse a seconda
dello stadio di cambiamento in cui si
trova per esempio lei ha già provato
diverse volte non c'è riuscita oppure la
prima volta che ci prova quindi le cose
si fanno complesse Allora come possiamo
intervenire con la comunicazione Beh il
primo la prima cosa da fare è
probabilmente quello di parlando con le
persone anche con Giulia di far leva
proprio su quei processi psicologici che
contano per lei possibilmente sapendoli
Ma quindi
dobbiamo trovare diciamo così anche la
chiave giusta la chiave giusta per
comunicare quello che conta non è tanto
quello che diciamo Ma se vogliamo
proprio il frame la cornice il modo in
cui noi lo diciamo per esempio se
diciamo a Giulia se mangi più frutta e
verdura ti sentirai più leggera
aumenterà il tuo benessere in questo
modo probabilmente attiviamo in lei
un'emozione anticipata positiva un senso
di soddisfazione se farà quella cosa Se
invece le diciamo se mangi più frutta e
verdura ti sentirai più appesantita e
ingrasserai in quel caso attiviamo in
lei un'altra emozione negativa
Probabilmente un senso di colpa o di
paura bene la domanda è Quale sarà il
messaggio giusto da mandare a Giulia
Qual è il messaggio che funzionerà
meglio c'è un messaggio migliore
A dire il vero no dipende da come è
fatta Giulia e cioè dipende appunto Da
quali sono i fattori che davvero contano
per lei e qui veniamo quindi al terzo
punto che è il teloring creare dei
messaggi che siano in sintonia con le
caratteristiche delle persone che ci
ascoltano per tornare al nostro
messaggio per esempio dire Guarda ti
sentirai più leggera aumenterà il tuo
benessere potrebbe funzionare di più con
una persona che crede poco nella sua
capacità di seguire una dieta una
persona che come diciamo a una scarso
senso di efficacia alimentare mentre a
una persona che si sente più sicura di
sé dice a figuriamoci io decido come
voglio Mangio quello che voglio potrebbe
essere più utile dire qualcosa del tipo
Guarda che rischierai di ingrassare di
appesantirti quindi attivarli
un'emozione un po' più negativa
fin qui la psicologia
Che cosa succede se come abbiamo detto
queste cose non dobbiamo dirle solo a
Giulia ma 10 100 1000 10.000 persone e
Cosa succede se i fattori in gioco come
già abbiamo visto sono tanti tanti
fattori che possono avere un peso
diverso in ogni persona e addirittura
come abbiamo visto anche avere un peso
diverso a seconda dello stadio di
cambiamento in cui la persona si trova
qui abbiamo bisogno di qualcosa appunto
un busto un potenziamento diciamo così e
allora Interviene a questo punto
l'intelligenza artificiale in che cosa
ci aiuta
Noi abbiamo raccolto dati abbiamo
raccolto informazioni su tante persone
ma è come se improvvisamente noi
potessimo anche proiettarci nel mondo
del possibile Grazie all'intelligenza
artificiale possiamo anche fare delle
ipotesi su persone che non abbiamo
effettivamente incontrato su messaggi
che non abbiamo usato ampliare diciamo
così le possibilità e mettendo appunto
dei modelli di tipo probabilistico per
l'appunto possiamo
ipotizzare quali messaggi potranno avere
più successo a seconda delle persone con
cui parliamo qui dietro di me Vedete un
esempio di questa macchina di questo
strumento diciamo così che riporta tutti
gli elementi di cui stiamo parlando da
una parte fa prende in esame tutte le
caratteristiche delle persone che stiamo
appunto
analizzando tutte le caratteristiche
possibili psicologiche che abbiamo
indagato poi tutti i messaggi poi
l'incrocia tutti e soprattutto Qualsiasi
cosa va a vedere va a vedere quali
potrebbero essere potrebbero è un
modello probabilistico Quali potrebbero
essere gli effetti a seconda del tipo di
messaggio che io manderò Insomma mi
consente di fare delle ipotesi a priori
come vedete è come si può intuire il
marchingegno quello che a volte noi
chiamiamo il frullino ma non è proprio
così un po' più complicato e appunto
abbastanza complesso Ma la cosa bella è
che alla fine tutto questo meccanismo Ci
dice tutto sommato qualcosa di semplice
Cioè chi abbiamo di fronte Che messaggio
è meglio mandarli quindi che il
meccanismo sia complesso Vabbè tanto è
la macchina che lavora ma l'esito può
essere anche come abbiamo detto
piuttosto semplice Se vogliamo cioè
possiamo selezionare il messaggio
migliore da mandare e non solo possiamo
selezionare quello che è meglio dire a
Giulia perché sappiamo come è fatta
Giulia Possiamo anche decidere capire
qual è il momento giusto della giornata
in cui mandare questo messaggio a Giulia
ma non solo siccome come abbiamo detto
Giulia passerà attraverso diverse fasi
in questo cambiamento possiamo anche
così fa la macchina e il chatbot il
conversatore automatico adattarsi ai
cambiamenti di Giulia e in questo modo
probabilmente Giulia riceverà dei
messaggi che sono che lei sente in
sintonia con lei e che probabilmente non
l'hai infastidiranno e quindi Qual è
l'esito diciamo così di tutto questo
processo Come è andata a finire
è andata a finire che Giulia in effetti
ha cambiato un po' le sue abitudini
adesso quando arriva la casa a casa la
sera cerca di fare delle cose un po'
diverse a volte esce a volte magari non
esce Però fa chiacchiere più lunghe con
gli amici insomma ha cambiato un po' ha
cambiato anche le cose che mangia mangia
cose più varie cose che le piacciono
comunque che però magari sono un po'
meno un po' meno caloriche e soprattutto
Giulia è contenta Giulia è contenta e
soddisfatta di aver fatto questo
cambiamento ed è contenta diciamo del
suo nuovo stato e quindi cosa è successo
che in effetti chi comunicando ha la
supportata L'ha accompagnata in questo
percorso ha usato una comunicazione che
a noi piace Chiamare Felice felice In
che senso è una comunicazione che
capisce le motivazioni le risorse le la
sensibilità di colui che o colei che ci
sta di fronte e in questo senso diventa
appunto qualcosa di felice allora sì che
possiamo intraprendere un percorso di
cambiamento con
entusiasmo perché attraverso la
comunicazione felice questo percorso di
cambiamento potrà essere completato
davvero con pieno successo
[Applauso]